hi in the previous module we looked at
modeling keys
this module i'm going to start talking
about inference in particular
introducing backtrackings
with dynamic or
so just a quick refresher remember a csp
is defined by a factor graph which has a
set of variables
and for each variable
on some values in domain of i
and it also has some factors
f1 through fm where each factor
fj is a function that takes a subset of
the variables and returns a non-negative
quantity
so the assignment
weight is defined as follows so each
assignment
to all the variables has a weight which
is given by the product of all the
factors
and the goal in finding this in solving
csp is to compute the maximum way to
assign it
so
let's start with backtracking search
which we already talked about a little
bit
so
the backtracking search is going to be
the kind of blueprint for the
current algorithm that we're going to
talk about
so if we start with
empty assignment no variable has any uh
and we
choose one of the variables a sign of
a particular value red in this case and
then we recurse and we pick another
variable assign a value in recursion so
maybe we believe and then we back up
uh backtrack and try green
um backtrack try
uh blue and then we backtrack up here
now we're gonna try setting wa green
out here explore this subtree and we
come back up
x
explorer nt green empty blue
and so on so forth
so at the bottom of this tree we have
the leaves
and
each leaf
is a complete assignment
and each assignment
has a weight
which we can compute
and now if once we search through all
the assignments we simply take the
assignment with the mac
so this is the most straightforward way
of taking a csp
and solving and using
a backtracking search
so the first thing we'll note is that we
can actually compute weight of
partial assignments as we go rather than
waiting until the very end to compute
the weight of an entire assignment
so this is how it's going to
proceed
so
um let's start with empty assignment and
we
assign wa red
and us
we can't evaluate any of the factors so
far
but once we assign nt
we can actually evaluate this factor
and test whether wa i want here
but these other factors we can't
evaluate yet because we don't know these
values but
values to these variables but we can
move on
um now we recurse we assign sa
value and now we can assign
we can evaluate these factors
um w not equal as a and nt not equal
and we assign q
we kind of evaluate these two factors
sign nsw we can just evaluate these two
factors
and assign v we can now
evaluate these two factors and these are
all the factors in csv
so at any point in time for example at
nsw
we have this partial assignment here
and we define the weight of that partial
assignment to be the product of all the
factors
that we can evaluate
where all the factors are evaluated are
evaluable if
all the variables scope of that factor
have been
so more formally
suppose we have a partial assignment and
lies as follows we're going to define
the set of dependent factors as follows
so d of a partial assignment x and a
particular variable x i
is the set of factors depending on x i
and x
but not on the unassigned variable
so for example d of this
partial assignment up here
and
this variable s a
are simply these two factors here
these are the factors that are going to
be multiplied in when x i
is set
okay so now we're ready to present our
main
back tracking search algorithm
okay so this is going to be a kind of
general blueprint for
many of the bells and whistles that
we're going to talk about
soon
so backtrack takes a partial assignment
x
and the weight of that partial
assignment which is all the factors that
we can evaluate so far
and domains which specifies
valid uh possible
values for each of the variables in the
csp
or on the saw in a bit
so if x is a complete assignment
then we have reached a leaf and we look
at its weight and we update um
our current best
and we return
if not we're going to choose an
unassigned variable x i
we're going to look at the values
in the domain i
of x i
and order them somehow
we're going to go through each value in
that order
and we're going to compute a weight
update
so we're going to look at this
assignment which is the x
extended with x i set to v
and then we're going to look at all the
factors in the dependent set of factors
of x the partial assignment and
new variable x i that we're going to
assign
multiply all the factors evaluated at
this extended assignment
so that number we're going to call delta
which is going to be the update on w
okay so if delta equals zero
then we stop there and don't recurse
further because remember
any zero
by a factor is enough to zero out the um
this uh the weight of the given
assignment
so if not then we continue we're going
to do this thing called look ahead which
takes the domains
and tries to reduce them tries to prune
away things
based on
this new assignment x i2
so now if any of these domains become
empty then we can again prune and
stop recursing
otherwise we're going to recurse and
backtrack on this extended assignment
with this updated weight w times delta
and the new domains that we've
completed okay so this
recipe has three choice points
how to choose the unassigned variable
how to order the values of the assigned
unassigned variable
and finally this look ahead which is how
we prune the
so we're going to talk about each of
these in turn starting with
the look ahead
so
we're going to introduce a simple form
of lookahead called forward checking
okay so first we're going to
visualize the domains of each of the
variables with this um set of valid
colors above the respective
so in the empty assignment
all the values are allowed
okay so now um we're going to
set let's say wa equals
red
so at this point two things happen first
we wipe out the all the other
values from that variable which is clear
that's wh we're committing to that
but in addition what we're going to do
is do one step look at forward checking
so we're going to eliminate the
inconsistent values from the domains of
xi's neighbors so in this case we're
going to look at the neighbors of wa
which are ntnsa
and we're going to remove red from those
domains
and why is that because this factor says
that well if this is red then this can't
be red
the red is gone now
okay so now uh
search is going to recurse
and it's going to let's say it sets a nt
to green
um so now again i do one step look at
look at the neighbors of nt and i'm
going to wipe out green from these
okay so suppose i recurse again
and now i set um
q to be
blue
so again one step look ahead i'm going
to wipe out blue from
my neighbors
now look what happens
essay has an empty domain
which means that there are no possible
values that i can set essay to to make
the assignment uh consistent
so when in this case if any domain
becomes empty i simply return
here
and this is important because
now all these other variables have not
been set yet
and rather than recursing and trying to
set them all sorts of different ways i
already know at this point that essay
is not
setable so i just stopped there
so this allows forward checking allows
me to use these uh domains to prove
okay so forward checking is also going
to allow me to um
choose an unassigned variable and order
the values in a variable i'll show
followers so suppose we're in this
situation so wa and nt have been said
i've applied forward checking to
propagate the constraints to
all the names
so now the question is which variable do
i assign next
so there is this heuristic called most
constrained variable
mcb
which simply chooses the variable that
has the smallest image
okay so
um what's uh the domain size here so
there's two elements of q
three elements here one element here so
sa
is the variable that has the smallest
domain it has only one element
and the intuition here is i want to
restrict the branching factor and choose
variables that have small
um
a branching
determined by the number of elements in
that domain
so the
second
choice point is once i've selected a
variable
how do i order the values to explore
so consider the following so i'm just
trying to assign a value to q
do i first try red
or do i try blue
so the idea behind this heuristic called
least constrained value is i'm going to
order the values of
the selected x i by
decreasing number of consistent values
of neighboring
okay so what does this mean
on this example so i look at q
and
remember i set this to red tentatively
and i propagate
um via forward checking to its neighbor
so i wiped out red here
and now i look at the neighbors and say
how many possible
uh consistent values are there so there
are two plus two plus two so that's uh
six
values
and what about if i set it to blue here
and i've eliminated blue from these
neighbors
and the number of consistent values is
one plus one plus two
which is four here six is larger than
four so i'm going to try red this k
so intuitively why does this make sense
i want to choose a value that gives as
much freedom as possible to its
neighbors so that i don't and run into
trouble and get things to be
inconsistent
and you can see that by
having red here and red here i have more
options for the neighbors ntn sa then
over here
if since i can only do green here and
you can if you look uh even one step
ahead you'll notice that this is already
going to cause trouble
okay so least constrained value
order the values
to in order to free up the neighbors as
much as possible
so
this might seem a little bit strange so
most constrained variable these
constrained value it seems superficially
kind of at odds with each other
but
there is a reasoning
which is that variables and values are
very
different
so in a csp
every variable must be assigned
so we don't we can't the left of leave a
variable alone and hope that the problem
will disappear later
so what we're going to do is we're going
to try to choose the most constrained
variables as possible so we're going to
fail we're going to choose the hardest
variables first to try
and we might as well fail early which
leads to more pruning
on the other hand
values are
those that we're going to choo we just
need to choose some value for each
variable
so what we're going to try to do is
choose the value that is most likely to
lead
to a solution
it doesn't matter if some value
is
going to cause trouble because if we
choose a value that happens to work
then maybe we'll be happy
so when do these heuristic help kind of
formally the most constrained variable
is useful when some of the factors are
constrained
it's okay if some of the factors are not
constrained
but it's important
that at least of one of the factors is a
constraint which means that
it's something that returns can return
zero if all the factors are returning
non-zero
values then none of these heuristics are
going to be helpful you kind of have to
explore everything
these constraint value is useful when
all the factors are constraints
in other words the assignment weights
are one and or zero
so they have to look like this but not
like this factor
and the rationale here
is that
we have to
uh we don't have to
find all of the assignments in this case
if we find
an assignment that has weight one
then we know we're done because one is
the maximum weight possible and we just
return immediately
and stop early
but if there's other factors which have
um varying values
or very weights of different magnitudes
then we can't necessarily stop if we
find a weight of two well maybe there's
a weight another assignment that has a
weight of four or eight or
17 or so on we don't really we can't
really stop early enough
and notice that we need forward checking
uh to make both of these things work
because these heuristics rely on
counting the number of elements in
domains and so we need to groom or prune
these domains so that the heuristics are
okay so let's conclude here so we
presented backtracking search
so backtracking search has uh three
choice points
first we need to choose an unassigned
variable x i
this is done by using a most constrained
variable mcv
once we found a variable to assign we're
going to order the values
of that
unassigned variable
based on the lcv heuristic or at least
strain value
and then we're going to
um compute the updated weight as
we discussed before
and then we're going to update the
domains
uh via one step look at aka forward
checking
and then if the number of uh
elements in any domain is zero then we
stop there and recurse don't recurse
otherwise
okay so notice that none of these
heuristics is guaranteed to speed up
backtracking a search there's no
theory here but
often in practice these can make a big
difference
the next time we'll look at
the look ahead and see how we can even
improve upon
checking
but that's it